not even if you want encouraging words
for family members these Syrians in
Berlin are never quite sure that letters
will reach their loved ones back home
the initiative civilian march for Aleppo
started by Anna al Baath is now making
this possible she and hundreds of
supporters want to reach aleppo on foot
in just three and a half months people
say it's naive or stupid and will not
change anything but I think for sure it
will lock change anything if you don't
do anything this is for sure other way
around let's see I don't say for sure
will I succeed with anything but we will
give our best to try the March itself
will be a major challenge and that's not
only because of the long distance and
the cold season but because so many
people with different beliefs and ideas
will be traveling together organizers
say political party symbols of those who
take sides in Syria's Civil War are not
welcome but not everyone agrees with
that decision it's very clear who is
bumping Aleppo so I think this like
peace without justice it's it's no peace
you know i am anna i'm leaving Berlin
I'm a mother of two kids and I have no
idea who is guilty of what and it
doesn't mean I cannot stand up for
saying that I don't agree with what is
happening yet let's go our kids are here
and they're off after only three weeks
of intense preparations the polish
journalist is on her way to Aleppo
whether she and her backers will ever
arrive or not is uncertain but this
March is her way of protesting the war
in Syria